what's the cat video cat adoption SPCA
goes nuts hi everyone we're Tegan and
Sara hi we have been asked to come up
with five YouTube videos that we enjoy
watching
we're three hours into trying to
remember the name of any YouTube video
we've ever seen it's one of those things
that's hard you see it's like telling
jokes like you think you know a lot of
jokes and then Winstanley I only know
one joke what did the zero say to the
eight nice belt homido got out go ahead
tell them your favorite okay my this one
always this is the funniest thing you've
ever seen it is it's the one that I
remember someone sent it to me like when
the internet practically got invented
and I was like this is a good place for
this video it's good wieners out it's
about a cat pinky don't tell them
everything just tell them the name of
the video on the watch it's pinky the
cat okay thank you the catch pinky the
cat just watch enjoy a few times
cats roll don't worry about the cat well
since we're talking about one named
YouTube superheroes the next video we
agree is in our top 5 of all time is
piffy the bellringer full version it's
about 7 minutes
[Music]
okay so one of the things that I
requested was that we took nice YouTube
videos like nothing to me
because we know a lot of mean ones that
we just watch and just weep with like
we're just weeping because I was
laughing so hard yeah you've been there
backstage I have video of it I have
video of you watching mean videos
laughing just in case you ever do
anything that bothers me so I can
release it onto the Internet
so what's a nice youtube video that you
like to watch Tara is the first to
return to the barn
she'll be the first elephant Shirley has
laid eyes on in over two decades when I
started dating the person I'm currently
with on our first date we watched that
video of the elephants being reunited
and we cried and knot-tying knew that
she was the one for me in their
desperation to get closer throughout the
night Shirley and Jenny have bent the
steel bars between them okay so I have a
video in mind that I think is this is
really funny it's so good okay it's the
one where the news caster throws to an
upsetting disturbing news story and it
involves a hamster all right I don't
know this we've never seen that I don't
think so that's watching this guy I
can't wait it's dark 16 year old Molly
bish disappearing wad her lifeguarding
job at a pond and Warren back in June of
2000 the possible suspect
Rodney Stanger seen here no no this is
not Rodney Stanga crap obviously well
the fifth video that I pick and this is
not mean this is classic and it's
hilarious it's not right on a
teleprompter I don't know what that is
I've never seen that everyone knows this
clip you're welcome if you haven't seen
it he has a meltdown it's the most
hilarious thing ever and every single
day when something bad happens we say
let's do it live that's tomorrow and
that is it for us today and we will
leave you with a I can't do it we'll do
it live do it a lot yeah do it live I
can't all right it and we'll do it live
it has been a pleasure to spend some
time with you and share our favorite
videos we hope that you will also while
you're on the internet check out our
record heartthrob or any of our many
many records we've put up 100
because we're vampires we've been around
for a hundred years we hope that you
will come see us sometime soon and if
not it does not matter yeah thank you or
or no thank you
doesn't matter yeah just right I just
wanna say this one thing the first video
that comes up the title is painful
testicular cat attack on live TV because
that is what happens in that guy